hello welcome back to new rocks there's
debrief I'm Erik Bosse and joining me
today are Sam basher hello Gary that's
my name and we have a special guest
today Ben Bateman he's a super health
super host himself he's interviewed
Avengers actors and you may know him
from Motown Collider tons of other stuff
welcome Ben thanks for having me I'm
excited to be here thanks for joining us
well guys it's been a huge huge week in
Marvel news right we've had all kinds of
stuff coming out between Captain Marvel
and Avengers endgame but today we are
talking about the breaking news James
Gunn is back as director of guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 and we're also gonna
talk about some of the other stuff that
we've seen this week some deleted scenes
from Captain Marvel
a game of Thrones theory about the night
king marvel's new what-if show on disney
plus and a quote damn near perfect DC
movie and don't forget that you can also
find this episode as a podcast we
actually just crossed a thousand
subscribers over on the himalaya app so
thank you guys very much for supporting
us there and you can find us wherever
you get your podcasts but we of course
appreciate it if you went through
Himalaya cuz they helped us out in other
ways but alright let's get started with
this big news that just came out today
this morning in fact Friday morning is
when we tape here in that the return of
James Gunn to direct the guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 so we heard today
apparently Disney was impressed with his
apology and basically changed their
minds on the decision they made before
they've been having meetings it sounds
like for a while now there's some rumors
about back channels that were going on
but eventually it all got worked out and
they announced it today that he's coming
back now whatever your feelings are
about this I think most of us would
agree that this is good news for the
movie and for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it had been postponed until who
knows when I heard that was coming out
originally 2020 but was pushed back to
2021 and now potentially 2022 Feige has
said really it's just been shelved for
the time being but maybe he was kind of
might miss tongue waiting to announce
this and none of our favorite
alternatives were willing to touch it
about you know what like we were talking
about maybe Tyco with TT would be a good
fill-in but he decided no he did not
want to direct this movie so it looked
like they didn't really have a lot of
good backup options and it was too much
to James guns baby you know he they were
gonna use his script it's his story a
lot of the castes rallied around him
especially dave bautista who's very
vocal about it and i think it sounds
like he wrote or he did write the first
two movies of this trilogy they were his
soundtrack it was in his voice in so
many ways so it makes sense that he
would come back and this would be the
first time a single director is directed
a trilogy within the MCU i mean you
should yeah so here's a one crazy
wrinkle in all this is that while James
Gunn and Disney were on a break I guess
we could say gun committed to writing
and directing Suicide Squad - oh boy
yeah crossover now they're very familiar
franchises if you think about it right
both redemption tales with a ragtag
motley crew who have to go on some
mission together now both of these
franchises gonna have the same writer
directors same author is gonna be the
visionary behind both of these and we're
hearing that the plan is for James gun
to shoot Suicide Squad - and then move
on to Guardians 3 so it sounds like he's
still doing both he doesn't have to pick
between them sounds like an ideal
situation if you really think about it
oh yeah yeah I'm super onboard with it
yeah well here's the thing though it's
it's gonna push guardians 3 back from
its original release date so how do we
think that's gonna affect the story of
the movie do we think it's gonna change
the timeline or is gonna close some
doors on where in the Marvel timeline or
open up some other doors maybe to do a
prequel when I say ideal situation I
mean for him like it sounded like he was
on top of the world and I got pulled out
from under him but obviously and some
people can see really good talent where
it is and there is a little thing called
redemption and you know all of us are
the same person we were 10 years ago so
that's kind of something but at the same
time like he's working for the enemy and
they're allowing it and they're
prioritizing it so that's kind of like
if he's gotta bring her a bit yes it's
it's a good place to land after you
stumble and fall and also I like that
they're waiting like David Yates when he
was directing the first fantastic Beats
movie beats beasts and he was also doing
that Tarzan rather a fantastic Bates and
where to find them in Spotify for
SoundCloud
but in that same year of the first movie
that he put out that Tarzan movie tune
it was like oh wait no no he it's okay
he directed both in the same year and
you're like what and that both movies
kind of reflect that it was somebody who
was very split so I'm glad like give it
a sec let the MCU kind of reshuffle like
you of your what if and your what have
shows and your Disney Plus shows coming
out that are tied to the MCU just like
let's see what other things organically
kind of pop up but you have your
eternals movie coming out as well I'm
glad like give it a break let Suicide
Squad to be what it's gonna be
and then come back for the finale for
guardians three and it's kind of like a
cool stamp at the end of this like this
phase of Marvel the Marvel Universe
story in a story go out with a bang I
think that if Suicide Squad - and
guardians 3 actually come together their
current production schedules there's no
disasters and they're both even halfway
decent I would be blown away there's
zero chance in my mind that happens I
think that the big weight on them
announcing this deal with him going back
to Marvel is probably that the DC was
just like look you can announce this but
we need a little more solid I already
out of you to make this project seem
legitimate first
yeah because Suicide Squad - has been
such a disaster to this point
I mean friend of mine was what the guy
was gonna direct it before Gavin
O'Connor and I knew a guy that did a
draft of the script and back to this
point to people and not from Gavin but
just the writers that have gone in it's
like draft script goes away draft script
goes away they can't figure out what to
do with the movie so hopefully he comes
in and he knows exactly what he's doing
and that movie can just be awesome
because I would love to see DC have a
win but I don't know how I feel about
that movie at this point what I don't
want to have happen
is that being a director of a Marvel
movie is the same as not being able to
land an Oscar host it's like it's such a
great you know job to be able to do but
because you have a lot of spotlight on
you it's like then for the internet to
kind of go in and delve in and try to
destroy them i I think we need to get
over that real quick or we all need to
collectively delete our histories right
I mean I think it's a bit of both right
I think we have to both watch ourselves
and and go back and try to be sensitive
and what we say if we're public figures
but I think it's also like we can
probably tame down this watchdog culture
and expecting everyone to be
ideologically perfect in all stages of
their lives and to not allow Redemption
and you would think especially with with
guardians of the galaxy how important
the theme of redemption coming back from
your mistakes like they all have read on
their ledger they all have you know
their criminal records printed on their
prison kill and prison uniforms and
that's just something that's part of all
of them they all share in common but
they all find some common humanity or
come in whatever gray said they all
share together because they're all
aliens and not even the same race can
can find that connection and fight for
mutual goals I'm I gotta be honest guys
I'm a little frustrated that I feel like
we've been brought through the wringer
on this it shouldn't have been even a
narrative at all like I don't I love
that we've been able to talk about it as
far as like having something to talk
about but it's just like it's annoying
that this was a controversy to begin
with it's annoying that like there had
to be like a hero's journey for James
Gunn rather than just like let him do
his thing and and make great movies in
production just because of you know
whatever dumb political forces in the
air it's something that we have to deal
with I think to get you the best part
about this is the example the Disney
setting here though we live in this
moment right now people use the phrase a
lot the culture of outrage we live in
right where something can take off on
Twitter and and the world will go nuts
for a day or two or three or a week and
people can lose jobs
it just it populates the liquid the
online conversation and companies very
often will feel that they need to make a
decision they need to make a show when
that happens to right or wrong to send a
message Disney is as big as it comes so
when that happened it was like we have
to do somethings if we don't do
something people are gonna think we're
not paying attention it's nice to see
that they decided you know what we can
make another statement we can say over a
year later we've looked at this we've
decided this guy deserves a second shot
we're not gonna just we're not gonna let
tweets from 10 years ago no other
evidence no other proof make our
decision on this and this guy deserves a
second chance it sets an example for
people and I think that's important
thank you know if we can use the Star
Wars analogy here where it's Darth Vader
it was basically like the most evil
person in the galaxy for majority of his
life and then he does one good thing at
the end and everyone's like yay
can we apply that just don't do a
trilogy of origin stories with James we
don't need to say where they came from
well I mean it's also like it's crazy
that this happened on in the same week
as we had Captain Marvel do considerably
well at the box office an endgame
trailer surprise in game trailer a lot
of us felt followed by the day after on
a Friday this announcement like I don't
want to encourage conspiracy type
thinking other than our Marvel Theory
videos but it's until we do it one thing
if you go back and watch Phillip
actually brought up in a past video that
Disney might be doing this by design
like the moment Disney fired James gun
that might have actually been a
suspension and they were there were back
channels this whole time you're gonna
lay low will detach you from the project
and then there will be like a hero's
welcome later on after we changed the
narrative after a really successful week
and they would have paid him for
exclusivity I don't think that they
would have planned or for seeing him
working for DC I think if there if there
was ever an intention to bring him back
they would have stopped that from
happening big time so they let him go
and then he got snapped up and they went
whoops my dear well maybe yeah I mean I
we don't know the details of his of his
contract you see what I'm doing right
now it's conspiracy thinking like we
don't know but getting back to the the
question of this this idea of how this
could affect guardians 3 it sounds like
there was still gonna use the same
script anyway even after he's detachment
which feels like it would have been
framed in a world that was pretty much
immediate after endgame but now since
it's gonna have to be pushed back let's
call it like two years maybe three maybe
four like it's crazy that it's gonna
take so long now to get that movie out
since they were so ready to go last year
it's it's they feel like they have to
kind of revisit and see where they're
where all their characters are at so
intertwined though it needs stage it's
just sorry tangled so to have to pick it
apart and like reboot it back I don't
know this is it possible that they may
do a prequel that because there was like
a four year gap between guardians to an
Avengers infinity war when we picked up
with them
star-lord got some differential hair
group grew up a little bit also like the
end story
he's like so the end story is infinity
war or in Hulk smashes into their
windshield and that's the end of that
stuff I mean the stakes are lower
because we know everyone makes it out
alive
but then you just introduce another
character there's some other kind of
goal they're trying to accomplish that
you're worried about I mean there's a
lot of exoti issues that they could keep
exploring there with Gamora and with
star-lord I mean I was kind of killed as
dad huh oh but if you think so Guardians
too has that weird distinction of being
that movie that like everybody really
liked it when they walked out of the
theater well liked I laughed my I'm in a
serious I thought that was great never
saw it again
it's like the 13th or 14th best MCU
movie by posting those lists like it's
pretty close to Captain Marvel by the
people who didn't like Captain Marvel
these guardians 3 gonna do better than
that it's like the Guardians 2 is so
similar to guardians 1 on it stone if 3
is the same thing like what's the point
of just not doing something like a
prequel what's the point of doing
another movie that feels so much like 1
& 2 if it's I don't know it just feels
hard to win there right yeah I would
love a reboot in a sense and it just
takes two or three of the characters and
makes like the way that Thor Ragnarok
was the sort of buddy comedy between
these two writers I would love to see an
offshoot story where it's just like
Groot and Rocket you know you don't have
to bring any live-action actors
something different I I honestly like I
like the way they've explored they've
kind of explored Gamora and star Lord
but we don't know anything about rocket
like whatsoever we don't know where he
came from we don't know where group came
from and we want to use at a Morlock
that's gonna be a big part of the story
since that's a genetically engineered
creature and so is rocket and so and we
don't know where groots from and so like
there could be a really cool like
parallel between those characters of
someone who is so perfect Adam is
supposed to be space Jesus he is
supposed to be the example of what
everything could be at one point and
then showing rocket who was an
experiment who turned out like the he's
constantly in pain and he's always angry
and it's like and he basically no one
takes him seriously and they can't even
like name him right they're like no he's
like a rabbit or he's like a rat or a
squirrel or a monkey or whatever and
it's like no one takes him seriously and
there could be a really cool story of
exploring that and it could be a good
final chapter where it's like star-lord
stories kind of done like basically he
can be there to support his friends and
whatnot but I would like to know more
about those guardians you know he needs
to be in that real bad huh Howard the
Duck yes what happened there
on the peripherals he's getting his own
animated movie like their show yeah yeah
yeah well we'll have to wait and see I'm
just glad that we're finally closing the
book on this whole like James Gunn story
at least hopefully because I remember
when the news broke that was the episode
where I was hosting this show by myself
and you guys were all at Comic Con
oh yes it got real weird and the journey
like pee-wee's Playhouse I was like
they're doing voices I kind of lost my
mind so that is like where I broke Dart
and now the loop is closed and I'm fixed
you bet and we're back on the model
timeline there we go that's great but
let's move on to our trivia quiz Lisa
Thank You gang you know this time of the
show it's my favorite it's my third
favorite probably but right now it's my
favorite this is the time where I'm
gonna ask you guys a trivia question our
hosts are gonna try to do their best to
get the right answer and whoever gets
the right answer is going to be able to
do our outro today but the loser
absolute failure which is usually not a
10 who's gonna have to pull from the gif
of shame box there's beautifully made by
whom's
Travis Keadle thank you so much all
right so go ahead get ready here is your
trivia question has always been
controversy associated with the creation
of Batman many credit comic writer Bob
Kane but some would argue blank was the
true creator of the Caped Crusader so
who was in some people's eyes to the
true creator of Batman okay all of our
answers are here in the bucket we'll get
to the answer later in this episode but
real quick we just wanted to take a
quick second to thank audible for
sponsoring this video slash podcast
episode audible has an insane selection
of audio books including Game of Thrones
which we're gonna start talking about in
just a bit also coming up on my list is
a book called
Batman and psychology a dark and stormy
night like with a K that I'm really
really excited about audiobooks are just
a great way to learn something new while
you're at the gym or you're in a waiting
room or cooking or cleaning just like
some of you guys are doing probably at
this moment as we listening to this I
love reading but it's hard to dedicate
time to just sit down and read a book or
sometimes string words together to form
sentences about Education audible solves
that problem
just keeps me for falling asleep in
traffic so thank you for saving my life
and to get started with a 30-day trial
when you go to audible.com slash
rockstars
again audible.com slash rockstars AUD
ible calm /r o ck s ta RS all of us are
learning to read Oh what are you reading
weed flex but I came would Sarah J
masses the masses of her novels very
thorough J mass with two A's if you like
fantasy I'm speaking of fantasy and
sci-fi there's a segue for you let's
talk about Captain Marvel it's out and a
lot of people had a chance to see it and
chatter online and the chatter online is
focused on what people didn't see
deleted scenes and concepts that didn't
make it into the final cut of the movie
so some people have pointed out scenes
from the trailer or promo images that
never happened like these that suggests
Ronan the accuser was originally a
bigger part of the film gasp labelled in
the credits as big boy number one for
our podcast owners there's one image
here rivers is leading the rest of her
group to meet Ronan and yon Rock and
another where jaan raghav Ronan the
accuser hang out on their own up being
buddy pals just hanging out being new
boys mingling a VFX artist also leaked
that there was a scene in which Yan Raju
laws character meets with Supreme
intelligence and the person he sees
meaning the person that he respects the
most is drumroll please he's himself
earlier before we start recording that I
think there's a joke about it in the
movie that's like is he your brother is
it yourself and he's just moving on
which explains why he is so cagey about
it in the movie makes it I love it
pretty fun and this was more of a
deleted idea than a deleted scene but
apparently one idea for a post-credits
scene was having us having we get to see
yon raw and anon Sekar which is the
planet Jeff Goldblum's character the
Grand Master rules and thor ragnarok
which is described as a trash heap in
the Solar System but what do you guys
think did these cuts and changes improve
the movie or would you have liked to see
these in this film well I mean we
couldn't have that little nugget about
yawn rug being an epic wanker because it
would have revealed who he was as a
person we needed to have a lot more of a
facade around him so that twist oh gosh
spoiler did we ever give a spoiler
warning for this okay I gave it the
erector range of visit twister I think
it would have not landed that blow hard
enough should be you have no none
information but I really like that
nugget I think it's cool I think it's
cool too I don't know how like narrative
Lee I don't know if it would have meant
anything to me specifically like juicy
why horror my dog that would be really
twice right yeah shut off the Dwight
Goodman voice sound lives and think of a
surfer bro from the 90s in a ski bro
from the 90s and then whatever voice you
think up that's what my dog sounds like
I would see Maya Angelou thinking I'd
see Bodie from Point Break Swayze with
the fool man whoa
that's who I respect most yeah mod GC
could have done probably it's
rhinosaurus Rex by the way I'll be like
I will listen to everything that's true
fear is respect for de cool I think it's
have a mixed bag I think I will say I
probably needed if I could make some
change if I could slide up a fader bar
it would just be to slide up Ronin a bit
we're in the movie just because it seems
like the promotional material T's that
he would be a bigger part of this story
but on the benefit it left me asking
questions and wanting to see more of
them if they ever bring him back into
sequel you know but it's I wanted to see
more of him than just like one of those
the Star Wars a hollow projector thanks
basically his entire role and there's
one scene where he's like huh she's
interesting and sick what was that like
that's a pointless he does inspire a
missile at one point well then I'm going
full spoilers for you a whole Ronin
thing is like you know with the end of
the movie when she's like they're just
full with spoiler she's all like crazy
and supernova wild she's super powerful
saying yeah super xanthus innocent and
he's like standing there and she's like
I'm just gonna like flying missiles and
stuff you're like this is not even
anymore cuz you're too powerful and
that's the only time Ronan's even in the
movie really he's like yes I think one
scene otherwise so it's just like this
whole like why was he in the movie you
know what was the point you know like
it's the most populous country we know
from the MCS I get why you'd want to and
he eventually he wasn't a zealot before
but then he became one that's why he has
like the military like prowess and
everything I get it you didn't really
you didn't really need him and I do like
the tease of using in the future but we
already know his fate
basically he's safe if they use him
again so it doesn't really matter last
week we're talking about what words have
you read but when you say them you're
like oh that's it time in this film
thanking myself and he was Ciaran Hinds
but actually that's just the bad guy
from Justice League like wow this makeup
is amazing
this is incredibly did this this is so
impressive than its Lea paced I was just
wrong so yeah that was my experience
yeah it's one of those moments abs
fruitcake yeah I can't say that's the
only word I read but you know what let's
read your thoughts in the comments down
below did you want more ronan or was
that enough yeah I vote enough yeah it's
just you could look at it from a lot of
different ways whose story was this was
kind of Nick Fury story almost as much
as it was Carroll's so maybe they felt
like we didn't want another competing
protagonist in the story or competing
the antagonist misdirected threat being
the scrolls and when the twist happened
I don't think that there was enough of a
threat at the second half especially
when she went for Super Saiyan so having
him right there being super powerful we
could have actually seen a little bit
more than oh now I've got to punch my
friend we're not even friends
ok poof you know good anyway let's move
on to game it's Ryan yes yes yeah there
is an interesting game of Thrones theory
going around this week about the night
Kings battle plans now it comes from
reddit unit user you slash the trip will
be they laid out a whole list of
predictions for the final season but
we're gonna focus on just one regarding
the night King and this is all
speculation
if you don't want to hear anything or be
persuaded by any thought process going
in then tune out because this could
happens who knows we're just suggesting
things so this theory is saying that the
night Kings Army is indeed headed to
Winterfell
Jaime has convinced a lot of the
Kingsguard to leave King's Landing and
join
there because that's what the threat is
so together with the northerners they're
going to emerge victorious however
though the night king himself will have
flown a Vissarion to King's Landing
which is gonna be unprotected more so
because their gods have left to go north
I don't know if you've seen what
Viserion can do with that gob but it's
blue fire or is it ice was it blue
flames or is it anyway everyone's gonna
be dead he's going to convert all of
those residents to whites of course and
then when you're on rocks up with the
golden company they're going to be
ambushed they're going to turn into
whites as well and all the south is
going to be the threat which we saw in
the Battle of the bastards where he goes
surrounded as well but the Knights of
the Vale came and rescued gosh I love
doing rewatch is cuz so what do you guys
think what would be more satisfying as
an ending to this whole conflict between
the living and the dead the
long-promised and much-hyped to showdown
at Winterfell or do you think that that
being taken care of and then move in
that fight down to King's Landing would
be even better to have that second
little o twist I would love that I love
this through this reddit user it's a
very cool thinking because I think while
we've been watching like the the footage
from the trailers and trying to figure
out where this all gonna go in these
final six very long episodes it feels
like a little messy like why is this new
army the golden company coming in this
late in the game like it feels too late
to have like a new yeah but like there's
so many other things in the books that
they've just let die out like there's
all these kind of characters like Lady
Stoneheart it was not a part of it but
it'd be great if like they could
simplify it this way you know rather
than having like the Cersei representing
the the war for the throne the conflicts
the political conflicts between humans
rather than like living versus dead I
would love for it to get simplified in
this way if like Cersei and the threat
she represents could be co-opted into
the knight Kings threat I love that
simplification so she gets tend yeah
notice she's pregnant and then
it could be like a baby night king
that's a worse idea go on with what you
were saying well I mean her whole whole
thing is to sit on the throne so she
needs a proper King now that Jamie's
gone she's been the queen leading my
gosh it would really solidify herself at
King's Landing I really like the
juxtaposition between the fact that this
has always been so summery and warm yeah
and then it'd be completely obliterated
other than the North even colder than
says he's hot
Oh baby is Cersei cold-hearted enough to
allow herself to be turned into a white
Walker or a white yes but she could also
raise the dead which are her kids and be
with her kids those kids obliterated in
the green trial there's enough for them
to come
oh yeah yeah where is the crypts there
because yeah half the city did go up
yeah to two of the Lannister kids were
born underneath that crypt it must have
been torched along with Tywin was his
body must have yeah tortured if they can
torch human body they can torch flesh
unless the night Kings white power
allows like like t2t 1,000 pieces to
come back together I mean I'm honestly I
like the idea of just kind of turning
it's on turning it on its head and
making the and just I don't like a false
sense of hope of moving like thinking
that the Army's gonna be able to take
him out at the north you stop them from
going further but it's like oh they
already there he beat you around 30 what
if I started melting like a jack they
had to go with winter but winters not
there you are the source of the seasonal
change like they don't normally have a
seasonal change in the game of Thrones
universe it's just these creatures bring
this seasonal force witness wherever
they go the cold goes with it it's like
an anime and movie
little storm cloud stays above their
head but it's a music you've said last
year you watched all of it all of it how
many hours how many I'm like how long
did it take you to go through it all
blended together I think I watched it
all in I said three weeks before but I
think it would be probably more true to
say six weeks
I watched it because it's ER each one
right they're like they're like 52
minutes or so and some are longer now
109 I believe actually considerably a
lot I'm currently on the middle of
season two yeah that's a commitment and
that's two seasons a week yeah I'm
behind guys you know I should be
watching it right now
you should we should all be watching it
right now well I see however whatever
twist happens because the Battle of
Wintle Winterfell is only happy in
Episode three we have three more
episodes after that battle happens so
there's gonna be some other major final
acts that happens after that that has to
be even more compelling or exciting or
climactic then that battle is so I'm
excited to see whatever that is and this
is my favorite theory leading into that
time travel I won no I went Daenerys
it'd be a full suit flame you know she's
gonna go and bring flame well another
thing that came out this week we learned
that Marvel is planning an animated
version of the what if comics from the
70s you may know those and they're
playing it for Disney plus they're a new
streaming service now if you don't know
the what if comics asks what happened
hypothetically if crazy changes happen
to your favorite comic book storylines
and in this new version led by Kevin
Feige he's been the one giving us all
the info about it it's gonna be doing
the same but for the MCU the live-action
MC that we know so we we know the
version of the vents that the Russo
brothers and and Joss Whedon and James
Gunn have kind of told us in these
different stories these are gonna be
taking those familiar tropes and turning
them on their head in different ways so
an example of one of those stories these
are all bonkers but one of them was what
if Loki got the hammer instead of Thor
oh no the what if the kodan son David
it was a different codon son essentially
so they won't be cannon the what-if
storylines are deliberately not canon
they're more of just like thought
experiments but that allows them to be
more fun in a way so the first question
I'm kind of curious about is like why
now for this like why does Marvel think
that now would be a good time
in particular for fans to really want
access to properties yeah I'm honestly
thinking like it's like what if x-men
were there in the beginning like okay
man here we go it's way cheaper we don't
the paper might hate you might get a lot
it might think definitely the money to
do that
theme song at least one time yeah I
think at this point they're they're just
like swinging for the fences repeatedly
Marvel and so it's sort of like we're
just do invest a lot of money and we're
gonna take as many chances as we can and
if we try seven and five work that's
fine it's pretty good and like you know
saying like I think what if also
represents like so many of like I grew
up reading comic books I grew up
collecting old like 70s and 80s comics
and they these are like literally the
quarter comics you'd find at comic
conventions you'd look at the cover and
like just the concept was the most
interesting part about it you didn't
even really they were like usually very
bad they usually weren't even that in
fact they were never more than one issue
they were like 22 pages I'm just like
nonsense
what if Aunt May had gotten bitten by
the radioactive spider she's more like a
spider skirt
[Music]
they just rewrote hers they used to
introduced her she is part of continuity
now it's spider-man yeah also like you
could do like spider-verse crossovers as
well like they have a character that I
would love to see on like any kind of
screen called spiders man and it's just
a group of spiders that thinks it's
Peter Parker it's absolute nightmare but
it's great because it always kind of
like talks about like eating people
butts like don't do that because we're
Peter Parker we don't do that so good
yeah yeah yes I mean yeah I think this
is this is perfect cuz we also just all
like they probably reached peak
familiarity among like lay people who
didn't grew up reading comic books they
all know what rocket is they're people
who have seen these people in movies so
you now have something to subvert in a
new storyline and it sounds like the
fact that it's animated is a really
smart way to go because we saw that
works so well and into the spider-verse
I think people are just much more
willing to accept more genre-bending
things happening when it's when
spider-ham is a literal cartoon that
looks like Warner Brothers Looney Tunes
I want to see this like a drunk history
what if and it's like just wherever the
story goes all right and I made it but
Sam you can attest to this the amount of
times where it's like a scenario happens
oh my what if what if it really did I
say it all the time like there's any
scenario much but yeah but what if to
the point where I was like what do you
my superpower is every time I said what
if whatever it was happened we would be
so screwed it'd be what if they what if
what if what is it yeah this is
basically what I'm trying to say is this
is catering directly to me no but what
if it wasn't last to last two pages I'd
say is that hate me if they did an X an
exile series where it's people from all
different universes come together and
form a team and they go from University
members helping out oh yeah they in the
most recent comic they had a cartoon
Wolverine named Wolvie and he would kind
of help out but he'd never hurt me he
didn't understand violence he didn't get
what the point of it was it's adorable
I was a cartoon characters like
spider-ham really like that also where'd
you go Sam oh oh oh the worst x-men ever
he's is it's a character who has the
worst look in the world and his only
ability is that he can explode but he
doesn't come back together I want to see
fat Hulk like do new ones they shouldn't
adapt the new the old ones that we're
familiar with
you should challenge themselves to think
out you know a a to see thinking there
yeah well I think there's probably gonna
be some sort of some of the classic ones
too cuz like like again you you know a
lot of like the premises you remember
we're just like the images like I think
there's one of those like what of Iron
Man was banished to Camelot oh yeah yeah
so I remember the images of like Iron
Man he's in like Knights armor like I
doesn't want to see the cartoon of that
I don't know think it'd be good
literally
he's iron what yeah he'll mama there yep
the sort I animator they're gonna get
like I love the voice actor the pretty J
and Chris Evans come on gang it's gonna
be like when Garfield was voiced by the
guy who did the voice of Bill Murray and
the Ghostbusters animated series then or
no Garfield whatever yeah cartoon car
filled in them and they made them
live-action movies so Matthew Lillard
didn't get voiced as scooby-doo and he
had a little bit of a tantrum on Twitter
by the way yeah so we but they got Will
Forte and that means it's available to
be shaggy in one of these what-if
scooby-doo was a part of the MCU
bing-bang-boom man thanks Howard the
Duck Wolverine cuz he needs someone who
sells in there and that's your special
pillared on the show
yeah put Lillard on the self up there
with not a shaggy action Lillard sigh
action figure Oh God ropes winches late
90s like I know what you did last summer
level Wing Commander actors do you wish
had gone on to be like in a true
a-lister like which one Freddie Prinze
jr. that's the one you wish oh yeah he's
the best he's the best he seems like
such a cool guy doing the guy who plays
Senor foggy wasn't he in one of those
movies who send your foggy foggy Nelson
from
daredevil he was like the best friend
character in rachel evans and freddie
prinze jr. which oh he was Jerry guys
she's all that she's all that you have
in the bathroom stall and heard of
Walker's evil plan
going down memory lane but he says
here's the best friend that says for you
link that's from Mean Girls so you go
what happened to him he's doing well we
gotta move on some short headlines again
in other news a new Aladdin trailer
Chloe seems like people are starting to
come around on a Will Smith's Genie give
him a second chance Twitter has been
abuzz about that we've got Stan Lee
confirmed of shot cameos for Avengers
endgame and for spider-man far from home
so as well as that intro we saw in
Captain Marvel we're gonna see more Stan
the next couple just kind of Bank those
exciting yeah I do I feel a little weird
by the time far from home comes out
right B let him rest I'd be fine with
the CGI stand
yeah or just like he's on a poster you
like in Deadpool to Oscar Isaac has said
that episode 9 will be the definitive
ending to the Skywalker story but rumor
has it Disney Plus might actually be
exploring a Star Wars Knights of the Old
Republic show that's kind of wild right
taking a nutty orange code guys guys
that's the best Star Wars video game of
all time and they're gonna you know show
I'm so excited this is a good thing we
always if we were always knew that this
trilogy was this guy walking trilogy
guys so Oscar come on more give us more
deets more spoilers but crotteau oh my
go guys
no but I know it's good like on
everything you're on IP Hogwarts but
it's Star Wars it sounds cool
really bad way to explain other news DC
is planning a Hawkman movie okay did you
read those old like the Geoff Johns
ragged Morales right oh but they haven't
here's a new series right now guys it's
Indiana Jones buddy flies but he
reincarnates buddy's an alien space cop
basically they didn't ever known what to
do with the character so they just keep
adding complicated storylines to them we
got a happen we need it so the Hawkman
movie will be successful is what you're
saying well speaking of successful DC
movies
according to people is damn near perfect
the early screenings reading crazy rave
reviews on Twitter I'm not yet seen it
oh no saying it I need to see it now
you're doing a two-week early screening
though I didn't have it forever cuz
legends of tomorrow kind of ruin those
care yeah recently I started reading it
it's Indiana Jones but he flies and I'm
so on board with that Sam's favorite
movie in the superior onra is the
version of Hawkman that exists in his
imagination right oh yeah that was
perfect
I say Hulk differently in there and
people make fun of me so it can't be my
favorite Hawk would I tried lightening
round though what we do want to share
everything with my boy
it's awkward so basically you guys will
tweet in questions we seen them each
week though and if you make it I'm gonna
read it out to whoever it's directed to
we have to do it super super fast so
make sure you're on Twitter every Friday
you can be on the show you with your
question um but yeah we're gonna have
that clock ticking guys so let's make it
fast Sam you're up this one's for Micah
Amiata what do you oh they're all what
if themed by the way they're all gonna
be whatever you should say what if the
way you did earlier if you wanted to do
your version of them yeah yeah deuce the
cat just straight-up eats Dennis yes
vote yes yes that or ant-man goes inside
his eye and they make goes bigger but
what if Sam Van at Catherine Bowen says
what if you're a billionaire would you
be Batman or Iron Man Eric we got at
Weber hovel two nine eight what if I
can't say that name well I'll give it a
real red-hot go no what do you if you
have to choose between Cersei and the
knight King to sit on the throne who
would you select Circe's made some very
bad choices so I say let's give the
night King ago Lord High at sky army one
two three four five one what is Thor and
Captain Marvel become a thing oh my god
during endgame no it's Captain Marvel
and Captain America for me yes I got
caught your joke someone did it you did
a gif of it it was absolutely perfect
can't have a ship without a captain
captains together what Sam punch clown
under school or three what if you'e
grant what if you were granted the
powers of Shazam as a kid what would
have been the first thing you did I mean
flight of the moon damn yeah really how
cool would that be and then I want to
come back down
I Drive make a giant lighting boy and
like I write my name and like a
cornfield what being a kid isn't it yeah
for sure
been at you see Joshua David says what
if Deadpool was in Avengers of in
infinity war what do you think he'll do
and what would be the outcome of it he
would make a movie r-rated no it made a
lot
money he'd be really funny and stano's
probably keep him alive for humor maybe
I don't know I'm not sure
oh that was not impossible lightning
more dad asked for seconds says if
Lincoln Zelda were characters in a game
of Thrones what houses would they be in
I mean all the houses I want to do all
of them link is definitely um I'm gonna
say night at his that he's into house
Tyrell because he's like the knight of
flowers really and he's also a
Gryffindor Zelda is a ravenclaw
but Zelda would be in not dawn Slytherin
dawn one hundred hundred Eric Weber
Bruce could never transform into the
Hulk again oh no thanks because why
would you put Ruffalo in the movie
otherwise you're gonna keep spoiling the
end and press junkets and also boys
would be so boring it he's only
interested for what he can turn into
sorry so charming aloo underscore six
minus six what if the Avengers could
only unsnap three team members who would
you bring back and why spire man yep
Black Panther group with you Ben we're
finishing this off apps the real took
twelve
what if endgame is actually terrible how
would that would that change how Disney
would handle the MC you know cuz one
flop they'll just keep making movies but
it would be the saddest day in the world
I'm so excited I can't even contain
myself for that movie so if it's
terrible I I wouldn't know what to do
with myself still be successful it's not
it's gonna be like the end of lost isn't
it it's gonna be like one of those
things where it's 100% though hey just
let me like it dammit
let me please you're gonna ruin it for
me aren't you yeah is it time now it
comes time for our 15 seconds shout out
where each of us has 15 seconds to shop
or plug or ramble about anything we want
Sam would you like to start
oh I'd love to thank you while you were
backing away from the microphone a
little bit I couldn't think of anything
but I'm vamping and using up my time
Brooklyn nine-nine I'm in it right now I
love it it's good giggles go check it
out
I mean you don't eat its popular
watching from my 15 seconds I had been
watching two series that I loved pin 15
on Hulu super funny reminds me of eighth
grade and a big mouth and way and then
Russian doll on Netflix
check them out okay for my 15 seconds
I'm gonna talk about the movie trivia
Schmo down it's this it's like WWE
except instead of hitting people it's
movie trivia Sam spit on it I compete in
it I've got a big live event here in LA
this weekend check it out remote on live
comm it's crazy awesome it's like my
favorite thing in the whole world
it's you love it you slowed down on the
time rain shout out to all the Easter
eggs that are happening in game with
friends that I'm catching now that I'm
we're coming to the end so I see in
season 1 season 2 episode 1 what goes
and threatens Baelish we slip slitting
his throat and I was like wow that's my
shadow that sounds awesome okay well now
we're gonna move on to our tribute
question we asked the answer the loser
who gets the worst answer has decided by
our judges will have to join the gift
shame Society and draw from this and
then act it out in front of the screen
and your stupidity will be turned into
an animated gif that people will share
far and wide now if you're listening to
us on the podcast I just follow us on
Twitter at new rock stars so you can see
whatever the hell we're talking about so
what was the question saying it was
there has always been a controversy
associated with the creation of Bettman
many credit comic writer Bob Kane but
some would argue Blanc was the true
creator of the Caped Crusader really
like the cadence of that by the way it's
a good one creator of the Caped Crusader
well Devin could good work from mod
didn't you just pick two names
william johnson doing you sound like a
president I'll be honest
Billy Johnson yes that's who wrote it
what name was popular actually well Sam
oh he's eager for us to know what he
said he said bill finger bill finger
William uh-huh
Eric said Jerry Siegel I see what you
were doing there it's a good guess my
strategy I don't see how it worked out
yeah man says bill finger to the answer
was yeah why don't have the answers it's
a face up bill finger his first time
getting credit for creating Batman was
in Batman V Superman and there's a
documentary called Batman and Bill and
it's really good it's on Hulu I really
recommend it it's really cold Batman and
Bill you should watch it it is very it's
very sad and it's very inspiring as well
so go check it out
well question Sam and Ben for both women
Co wedding so between Maude and I judges
who is furthest away but God it kind of
ride with the bit what if you had one of
the counter heels an actual comic my
finger on it
Billy what do you wear Devon you have to
bleep that right but let's keep track of
like yeah Maude never loses this guy
despite saying a real person which GG
comic to the forties final hey lose in
every video when I mispronounce Loudred
and a peon
all right so the gif of shame I'll have
to act and take this video or take the
gift of this and share it from our
Twitter here's what I have to do my
thumbs are talking about me right in
front of me that's what I have to do
mm-hmm and I'm just reacting I guess to
it there you go and while you do that
we'll be doing the outro we'll split it
I'll go and kick it off and we'll just
read what's on the what comes naturally
on the teleprompter but yes gang thank
you for joining and thank you for
watching or listening to this week's
episode of new rockstars debrief I want
to thank our hosts Maude Garrett at
Maude Garrett Sam bachelor that's me at
Sam basher at Eric vos ei vos plus our
special guest Ben Bateman at Ben Ben
Bateman media now reminder this is
available in audio and video form videos
at youtube.com slash new rock stars and
you can get the audio anywhere you get
your podcast but if you have the
Himalaya app you can actually leave
comments on the podcast and support the
show directly go ahead comment tweet and
asset new rock stars like this video
podcast share around subscribed any rock
stars for deep dives into the stuff you
love see you next week everybody we'll
see you later bye bye Eric lost Eric
lost everybody Eric lost Eric you got
one of my fingers who decided to defend
me to the others
[Music]